GOOD
ACTORS- WONDERFUL DURING THE
QUARTER- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SERVICES. WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH.
IN OPERATED WITH. YEAH COMMITTEE
OUR SYSTEM I THANK YOU- COME ON
THE FIRST FLOOR FOR THE PURPOSE
. OPPORTUNITY AND WATER NUMBER.
ONE YEAH BONTA. I DON'T THINK
OFFICE IN THE OFFICE ARE BILL TO
MAXIMIZE OUR FOR SAY PURCHASE IN
OUR HEARINGS AND TO THAT END ALL
NOW SHARE A FEW NOTES ABOUT THE
LOGISTICS OF OUR HEARING TODAY
REGARDING THE PUBLIC ACCESS TO
THE DISCUSSIONS TODAY ROOM FORTY
THIRTY SEVEN WE ARE CONDUCTING
AN IN PERSON HEARING. FACE
COVERINGS REQUIRED FOR ALL
MEMBERS EMPLOYEES AND THE PUBLIC
IN ALL COMMON AREAS AND SHARED
SPACES INCLUDING THIS HEARING
ROOM REGARDLESS OF VACCINATION
STATUS IF ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY ON THE BILL PLEASE RAISE
YOUR HAND AND I'LL ASK YOU TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. PLEASE
DO NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE. FOR
DIAL WITNESSES WILL BE USING A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE.
THROUGH WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN
TESTIFY ON A BILL. THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR
THREE SEVEN YOU CAN ALSO FIND
THIS NUMBER ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV
SCREEN. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE DO SO NOW THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE PLACED
IN QUEUE. BASED ON WHETHER YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE A BILL. WHEN
CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MEETING YOUR LIVE STREAM
BROADCAST AND YOUR SMART DEVICES
TO REDUCE THE SOUND DISTORTION.
THIS ONE IS A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
DISRUPTIONS. I WANTED KNOWLEDGE
TO THE ASSEMBLY HAS ENCOUNTERED
REPEATED DISRUPTIONS OF ITS
PROCEEDINGS IN RECENT YEARS. AND
THIS IS RUSSIAN HAVE INCREASED.
RECENT DISRUPTIONS OF GOVERNMENT
PROCEEDINGS ASSEMBLY AND AT THE
US CAPITOL NECESSITATE
CONSISTENT ENFORCEMENT OF LAWS
AND RULES AGAINST DISRUPTION
CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS DISTURBS
OR OTHERWISE IMPEDES ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF THIS HEARING IS
PROHIBITED IF DISRUPTIVE
BEHAVIOR OCCURS TODAY. YOU'LL BE
REMOVED FROM THE HEARING ROOM BY
THE ASSEMBLY SERGEANTS OR YOU
WILL BE REMOVED FROM THE CALL.
SO I BELIEVE WE HAVE ENOUGH FOR
A QUORUM. SO SECRETARY CAN CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE. CALDERON STATUS
HERE ARAMBULA BONTA. BRIAN CHOI
STONE. VEHICLE TO DO UP HERE.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
WOMAN VALLADARES WOULD YOU LIKE
TO OPEN ON AB THREE TWENTY ONE
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB THREE TWENTY ONE WILL
HELP SOME OF OUR STATE'S MOST
DISADVANTAGED CHILDREN LOW
INCOME DAHLE ENGLISH LEARNERS TO
BE ELIGIBLE FOR A PRIORITY
ENROLLMENT FOR STATE CHILD FOR
SERVICES AND PRESCHOOL.
UNFORTUNATELY ENGLISH LEARNERS
TYPICALLY LAG BEHIND THEIR
NATIVE ENGLISH SPEAKING PEERS
ACADEMICALLY. THE PERFORMANCE ON
STATEWIDE TESTS CONSISTENTLY
RANKS LOWER THAN THAT OF ANY
OTHER MEASURE CATEGORY OF
STUDENTS MANY ENGLISH LEARNERS
WHO ARE UNABLE TO ATTAIN ENGLISH
PROFICIENCY FACE MULTIPLE
MULTIPLE DIFFICULTIES IN THE
CLASSROOM. EVERYTHING FROM
UNFAMILIARITY WITH VOCABULARY
AND CULTURAL CONTEXT TO FEAR OF
IN CLASSROOM PARTICIPATION
CONTRIBUTE TO THE POORER
ACADEMIC OUTCOMES. THE CODE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS WORSENED
THE ACADEMIC OUTCOMES OF MOSUL
LANGUAGE LEARNERS AND ENGLISH
LEARNERS. THE LA UNIFED SCHOOL
DISTRICT REPORTED THAT THE
PERCENTAGE OF ENGLISH LEARNERS
FAILING THEIR CLASSES HAS
INCREASED TEN PERCENT.
SACRAMENTO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT ALSO REPORTED THE OTHER
STUDENTS THAT STOPPED REPORT
REPORTING TO CLASS OVER 44% MORE
ENGLISH LEARNERS. LEARNING
ENGLISH IS TOUGH AS IT IS BUT
LEARNING AND ISOLATION AT HOME
WITH FEWER RESOURCES HAS MADE IT
MUCH MORE DIFFICULT FOR DUAL
LANGUAGE LEARNERS AND ENGLISH
LEARNER LEARNERS TO BECOME
PROFICIENT. UNFORTUNATELY
ENGLISH TO ACHIEVE ENGLISH. ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE LIKELY TO
SUCCEED. IN THE CLASSROOM THAT
ENGLISH LEARNERS IN GENERAL.
WHAT POLICY INSTITUTE OF
CALIFORNIA REPORT FOUND THAT
THROUGHOUT GRADES TWO TO ELEVEN
FORMER ENGLISH LEARNERS WHO
BECAME PROFICIENT IN ENGLISH
SCORED SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER ON
STATEWIDE TESTS THAN ENGLISH
LEARNERS IN GENERAL. AND EVEN
HIGHER THAN NATIVE ENGLISH
SPEAKERS DID IN SOME OF THE
GRADE LEVELS. A RECENT
UNIVERSITY OF CHICAGO STUDY
CONFIRMS THAT ENGLISH LEARNERS
WHO ACHIEVED ENGLISH PROFICIENCY
BY EIGHTH GRADE ACTUALLY
PERFORMED AS WELL AS AS IN SOME
CASES BETTER ON TESTS THAN THEIR
NATIVE ENGLISH SPEAKING PEERS
DO. THE SOONER ENGLISH LEARNERS
LEARN ENGLISH THE MORE LIKELY
THEY ARE TO PERFORM WELL IN
SCHOOL AB THREE TWENTY ONE HELPS
LOW INCOME DAHLE LANGUAGE
LEARNERS IMPROVE ACCESS TO
VITALLY IMPORTANT EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION. BY MAKING
THEM ELIGIBLE FOR PRIORITY
ENROLLMENT FOR STATE CHILD CARE
SERVICES AND PRESCHOOL AB THREE
TWENTY ONE OFFERS ONE MEANINGFUL
WAY FOR THE STATE TO HELP LOW
INCOME BUILDING WHICH LEARNERS.
TO BETTER REQUIRE ENGLISH
LANGUAGE PROFICIENCY BEFORE THEY
ENTER TO K. THROUGH TWELVE
TESTIFYING TODAY I DO HOT IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE TWENTY ONE
AS BRIAN BOEHNER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PARENT TEACHER
ASSOCIATION. BRIAN AT HEAD
MISTER VAN WAGNER. OKAY CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES YES SIR OKAY GOOD
AFTERNOON- COMMITTEE CHAIR
CALLED AROUND AND MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY GAMES SERVICES
COMMITTEE I'M BRIAN BONNER
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA STATE
PTA WHICH SUPPORTS AB THREE
TWENTY ONE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VALLADARES. EIGHTY THREE POINT
ONE WITHIN A PRIORITY FOR THE
ENROLLMENT OF THE LANGUAGE
LEARNERS. ESTATE SUPPORTER
PRESCHOOL AND CHILDCARE PROGRAMS
THE PROVISIONS OF THE BILL ARE
CONSISTENT WITH LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES OF CALIFORNIA STATE
PTA. INCLUDING ADVOCATE TO
ACHIEVE JUSTICE FOR ALL CHILDREN
YOUTH AND FAMILIES THEY HAVE
THEIR ESSENTIAL NEEDS BEST.
ADVOCATE FOR FULL AND CULTURALLY
RESPONSIVE CURRICULUM TO MEET
THE DIVERSE NEEDS OF OUR STUDENT
POPULATION. BOTH PHYSICAL AND
MENTAL. WELL THAT'S A BEGIN IN
EARLY CHILDHOOD. FURTHER THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PTA BELIEVES
THAT ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS
MUST BE PROVIDED EDUCATION THAT
WILL ALLOW THEM THE OPPORTUNITY
TO ACQUIRE THE SKILLS NECESSARY
TO REALIZE THEIR FULL POTENTIAL
. IT SUPPORTS EFFORTS TO ENSURE.
THAT ALL CHILDREN HAVE
OPPORTUNITIES INCLUDING ACCESS
TO HIGH QUALITY DEVELOPMENTALLY
APPROPRIATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS
THAT DEVELOP THE READINESS
SKILLS THEY NEED TO BECOME
SUCCESSFUL ACADEMIC LEARNERS.
CALIFORNIA STATE PTA OFFERS THE
FOLLOWING COMMENTS ON THE B.
THREE TWENTY ONE. AB T. TWENTY
ONE WOULD ENSURE LOW INCOME BILL
LANGUAGE LEARNERS ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR PRIORITY ENROLLMENT IN STATE
CHILD CARE SERVICES AND
PRESCHOOLS. BY CREATING ACCESS
TO THE SERVICES FOR THE LANGUAGE
LEARNERS THIS BILL WOULD HELP
MORE- THE LANGUAGE LEARNERS
ACQUIRE ENGLISH LANGUAGE
PROFICIENCY AND BE BETTER
PREPARED FOR EIGHT TO TWELVE
SCHOOLS. UNFORTUNATELY ENGLISH
LEARNERS- LEG BEHIND THEIR
NATIVE ENGLISH SPEAKING PEERS
ACADEMICALLY. THE PERFORMANCE OF
CALIFORNIA ENGLISH LEARNERS A
STATEWIDE TESTS CONSISTENTLY
RANKS LOWER THAN THAT OF ANY
OTHER MEASURED STUDENT GROUP.
HOWEVER STUDIES CONFIRM THAT THE
SOONER ENGLISH LEARNERS LEARN
ENGLISH THE MORE LIKELY THEY ARE
TO PERFORM WELL IN SCHOOL. ONE
WAY THAT CALIFORNIA CAN HELP
ENGLISH LEARNERS LEARNING WAS
EARLY ON IS TO PROVIDE THEM
EARLY EXPOSURE TO ENGLISH IN
CHILD CARE AND PRESCHOOL
SENTENCE. BILL LANGUAGE LEARNERS
THAT ARE ROLLED INTEL CARE
PRESCHOOL. ARE FOUND TO EXIT
THOSE PROGRAMS WITH VASTLY
IMPROVED ENGLISH LANGUAGE AND
LITERACY SKILLS. ALL CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA REGARDLESS OF WHAT
LANGUAGE THEY SPEAK SHOULD HAVE
OPPORTUNITIES TO ACCESS HIGH
QUALITY- DEVELOPMENT APPROPRIATE
CHILDCARE AND PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS
. BUT THEY BEAT THE TWENTY ONE
THE LEGISLATURE HAS THE ABILITY.
TO INCREASE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
CALIFORNIA'S LOW INCOME BILL
LANGUAGE LEARNERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES. I BELIEVE THAT THIS
BILL WILL HELP PROVIDE THESE
CHILDREN A STRONG STRONGER A
FOUNDATION. IN THE ENGLISH
LANGUAGE A POLICY CAN BETTER
LEARN IN ENGAGING EIGHT TO
TWELVE CLASSROOMS. I THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
OUR SUPPORTER OF AB THREE TWENTY
ONE TO THE ASSEMBLY HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
MISTER BONNER. I DO WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC SUPPORT- IN
THE ROOM. OKAY SAN NINE TO HAVE
ANY ADDITIONAL PUBLIC SUPPORT ON
THE PHONE LINE. OPERATOR LADIES
AND SEVEN THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB
THREE TWENTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
TWENTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE.
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
MOMENT WHILE WE GATHER THE LINE
NUMBERS.
NINE FIFTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU NICK ROAMING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC
CONFERENCE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ONE MOMENT WE DO HAVE TWO MORE
COMMENTS IN Q. THANK MIND
FOURTEEN THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON COULD
ALLOW THE WITH THE TALKS ARE LAW
CENTER PERSONALLY WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR HER WORK ON CHILD
CARE AND HER LEADERSHIP ON THE
ISSUE- WE WHILE WE ARE NOT IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION WE ARE
NEUTRAL ON THE BALLOT. WE WANT
TO SHARE OUR CONCERNS ABOUT ALL
FAMILIES THAT ARE ON THE WAITING
LIST ADDING ANOTHER PRIORITY
CATEGORY- WHAT IMPACT TO THEIR
FAMILIES HI NEED. AND MAKE THEIR
WAITING TIME LONGER WE RECOGNIZE
THAT DUAL LANGUAGE LEARNERS ARE
IMPORTANT POPULATION OF CHILDREN
NEED CARE AND PREHEAT THE IMPACT
OF THE BELL WE WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
BUT WHAT THE CONSEQUENCES OF
ADDING ANOTHER PRIOR YOU CARRY.
CATEGORY THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NINE THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE NAVNEET PER YEAR ON
BEHALF OF THE STA AND SUPPORT WE
REPRESENT CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES
THROUGHOUT- PUBLIC PRESCHOOLS IN
THE STATE AND UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANT ROLE PRESCHOOL PLAY IN
THE LIVES OF CHILDREN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS IN Q. THANK YOU
OPERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY PRIMARY
OPPOSITION. WITNESSES IN THE
HEARING ROOM. CASEY NINE AM
OPERATOR TO HAVE ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES ON THE PHONE LINE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY
THREE TWENTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF AB
THREE TWENTY ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. WITH NO
COMMENTS IN Q. IS THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC OPPOSITION ON
THE PHONE LINE OPERATOR. WE HAVE
NO COMMENT IN Q. FOUR OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. OKAY DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR THE AUTHOR- IF DAVIS
. I WANT TO THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BRINGING THIS UP AND
PRESENTING IT OBVIOUSLY WITH
COAL BED AND THE LACK OF
LEARNING THAT OUR OUR CHILDREN
HAVE GONE THROUGH- AND THEN I
BELIEVE ONE OF STEPS YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT WAS DIGITAL 10%
EVEN LOWER WHEN IT COMES TO MATH
AND- IN READING SO THIS IS.
REALLY IMPORTANT I GREATLY
PROJECT BRITNEY FORWARD AND I
WOULD LOVE TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CO AUTHOR AS
WELL. THANK YOU. ABSOLUTELY
WOULD LOVE TO HAVE YOU ON AS A
CO AUTHOR. ASSEMBLYMAN BONTA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING
FOR THIS BILL I THINK THAT WE
WILL QUICKLY LEARN THAT I AM A
PASSIONATE ADVOCATE AND FIERCE
FIGHTER FOR CHILD CARE AND
REALLY APPRECIATE SPECIFICALLY
THAT YOU ARE ALSO UPLIFTING THE
IMPORTANCE OF ENSURING BY
LITERACY. OF FOR OUR FAMILIES
WHO SPEAK OTHER THAN ENGLISH AT
HOME. IN THIS TIME ESPECIALLY AS
WE KNOW THAT THAT PARTICULARLY
FOR THAT PORTION OF OUR
POPULATION WE HAVE EXTREME AND
IT ADDED EXTREME DISADVANTAGE IN
TERMS OF BEING ABLE TO BE
PREPARED FOR KINDERGARTEN AND
BEYOND SO I REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT YOU'VE GOT SUPPORT. THE
MEMBER BRIAN. W. SO DAVID AND
BOUGHT THE- ACT THING TO I HAVE
I'M REALLY EXCITED TO MAKE THIS
MY FIRST YES VOTING COMMITTEE-
THIS YEAR SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. OKAY ASSEMBLY WOMAN
VOLUNTEERS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I JUST LIKE TO THANK THE
CHARWOMAN AND COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR WORKING ON THIS BILL WE DID
ACCEPT- AMENDMENTS EARLIER IN
THE YEAR TO CLARIFY- SOME OF THE
INTENSE AND WE GLADLY ACCEPT
THOSE AMENDMENTS AND I.
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU I'M REALLY EXCITED THIS IS
THE FIRST BILL TO THAT WE'RE
HEARING THIS YEAR FOR A GOOD WAY
TO START THE YEAR. OKAY SO WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SOME WOMEN
ARAMBULA SECOND BY SOMEONE
ABILITY- THAT- AND SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO ASSEMBLY EDUCATION
COMMITTEE. CALDERON AYE CALDERON
AYE DAVIES THANK HI ARAMBULA ALL
RIGHT REGULAR PRICE. HI BONTA
BRIAN BRIAN I CHOI. STAY DONNA
HI WHO GOOD LUCK IF WE DO A-
THANK YOU WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ANY OF MEMBERS- HEARING
TO TURN. OKAY THE HEARING TURN
THANK YOU.